the day after Taiwan's historic election
reelecting pro-independence president
signed when the people of this island of
24 million enjoyed their winter Sunday I
hope that both Taiwan and China will
show good well China should stop its
military threats to war Taiwan I believe
she's the right leader to deal with
China I do not think she would try to be
confrontational after last night we vote
to still remain part of a big family
though we differ in political opinions
we share the same firm belief in
democratic values with the overwhelming
victory for sine when and the DPP some
feel that there's added pressure for
progress and recognition from China and
Beyond on the security of the islands
independence in Saturday's election side
garnered the most votes of any
presidential candidate and the young
democracy here promising to keep her
hardline stance for independence with
growing pressure from China Beijing
issued a statement shortly after Tsai
gave her victory speech as if the
landslide election never happened
President Xi Jinping's administration
continued with its threats of
reunification and its opposition to any
separatist attempts but her challenges
won't only be on improving cross-strait
relations Taiwan's economy has been a
major political issue here even if there
has been a recent boost thanks to the
us-china trade war she is under
tremendous pressure much higher than her
first term to perform better on the
economy
she was really defeated in the local
election about 15 months ago because of
the economic situation that didn't go
away so amid the saber-rattling from
China and calls for economic reform
sighs next four years start off with
major challenges but she goes into her
second term with the confidence of the
majority of Taiwanese people at least
for now
Scott Heidler al-jazeera Taipei